هل طلبت في اجتماع مع
الرئيس من كل ليلة من ليالي مورغان في
سيول ، ليس هذا العام
ولا العام الماضي ، لم نتقدم مطلقًا بمثل هذا
الطلب لعقد اجتماع مع
رئيس الولايات المتحدة من المسؤولين الأمريكيين ،
تلقينا ثمانية طلبات لعقد
اجتماع وأنا  لم أرى
أنه اجتماع مناسب لأنني لا
أرى أنه مناسب الآن
ويجب أن يعقد الاجتماع في وقت
يمكن أن يخدم فيه هذا الاجتماع غرضًا يمكن أن يكون
مفيدًا يمكن أن يخدم فوائد
كلا البلدين ولكن في ظل الظروف الحالية
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالاجتماع
والحوار ، فأنا لا أرى أنه
مفيد ولا مناسب ، لكن
يجب أن تسأله من الذي قدم مثل هذه الطلبات ،
فما الذي سيعيدك إلى التفاوض
مع الولايات المتحدة ، فأنا أقول
ذلك لأننا  يقول إننا بحاجة إلى
إعادة التفاوض ، نحتاج إلى فتح
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني المعروف باسم jcpoa الذي السيد.
ترامب السيد.  بومبيو الآخرون قالوا إننا
نريد التفاوض مع الإيرانيين لكن على
إيران أن تغير سلوكها ، فماذا
تقول في هذا البناء الجيد الذي تراه
بعد سنوات عديدة من المفاوضات
والحوار تم التوصل إلى إجماع وتم التوصل إلى
اتفاق بين الدول السبع
و  تم الاتفاق عليها من قبل
قيادة تلك الدول السبع
المعنية والتي تمت الموافقة عليها لاحقًا في
مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة
بموجب القرار 2231 ،
لذلك لا يحق لأحد
الخروج من مثل هذا الاتفاق من جانب واحد دون سبب عادل
ولا يمكن أن ينتهك الأمم المتحدة.
وعليه فإن قرار مجلس الأمن
انحرفت حكومة الولايات المتحدة
عن مسارها خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية
ويجب عليها العودة من ذلك
المسار المنحرف إلى النقطة السابقة إلى
نقطة الانطلاق وستكون هناك
نقطة يمكننا الحديث عنها فيما إذا كانت
هذه الاتفاقية  يتم تنفيذها بشكل جيد ،
هذا ليس الوقت المناسب للحديث عن
أي شيء آخر لإجراء حوار حول
أي شيء آخر قبل ر  o التنفيذ الصحيح
والدقيق للاتفاق السابق
الذي تم التوصل إليه